what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video I wanted to have a discussion
about a character who I consider to be
largely underrated in the world in the
realm of Marvel Comics and there's a lot
of characters like this there's a lot of
guys who just don't get a lot of
representation they're in for a couple
issues they might even be in for a small
storyline and then they're never seen or
heard from again in this video we're
going to talk about a character named
graviton now in order to understand what
it is that graviton can do we have to
understand the principles of gravity
here in the real world so you can make a
comparison and you can understand
exactly where he stands and what it is
that he's capable of in the realm of
quantum mechanics and physics there is a
theoretical particle called a graviton
now we don't know if this particle
exists or not there really hasn't been a
lot of investigation done and without
going into a great big huge discussion
on quantum gravity and quantum
electromagnetism we're just going to say
that this particle is kind of unknown to
us now the gravitational pull of an
object is relative to the density of
that object
now just because an object is large does
not mean that it is dense take the
planet earth for example the planet
Earth is colossal compared to the size
of your average human being according to
the CDC the average man here in the
United States is about 5 feet 7 inches
and about 195 pounds now you may be
strong enough to physically punch
through a piece of wood or to even punch
through a piece of concrete but on the
molecular structure on the atomic level
you're largely empty space now the earth
is exactly the same way on the atomic
level the earth is largely empty space
but if we were to remove that empty
space and condense the earth down to a
point where the nucleus of every single
atom in every single particle that
composes the makeup of the earth were
crammed together the density would be
infinite and the gravitational pull of
the object would be of the earth would
be infinite in effect the planet Earth
were turned into a black hole it would
simply just rip a hole in space and time
and just start sucking everything into
it now in the world of Marvel Comics the
graviton is held to be as an existing
particle and
Komets is held to be absolute that this
particle does exist now because this
particle is what creates gravity or
creates the gravitational pull of an
object graviton is able to manipulate
this and so in effect he simply just
manipulates gravity and he's able to
achieve a wide array of effects by
manipulating gravity he can decrease the
gravitational pull of an object even on
himself and effectively grant himself
the power of flight he can increase the
gravitational pull of an object and make
things heavier he could take somebody
and say you know and and increase the
gravitational pull around them and only
around them so that instead of the earth
pulling them at 9.8 meters per second
squared the earth might be pulling them
at a hundred meters per second squared
in which case they would just be
completely annihilated in addition to
these particular attributes he also has
the ability to isolate a particular
object and change its gravity so
gravitational pull there was a there was
an instance I think when he was battling
the Avengers over New York it was
somewhere around I think the the time
that he returned after he was exiled
into space
where he had where he was fighting the
Avengers and he actually enhanced the
gravitational pull around a rock and it
pulled all the Avengers towards the rock
now bear in mind he's not by any means
the most powerful Marvel character ever
but an ability to manipulate gravity to
me put someone near or extremely close
to Omega level status and the reason why
I say that is because mutants who
demonstrate the ability to alter the
fundamental principles of the planet
Earth are mutants who are for the most
part considered to be Omega level storm
for example has vast weather
manipulating abilities Iceman has the
ability to remove heat from a particular
area but the result being absolute cold
I mean cold is simply just the absence
of heat you can't really create cold you
can just take heat away from an object
now the reason why storm is considered
to be Omega level is just because of the
fact that her ability to manipulate the
weather could change the entire
ecosystem of the world with ice man it's
the same way with enough time and enough
energy and enough power H man could
drain all of the heat out of the planet
Earth into himself perhaps take on some
colossal form we don't know what would
happen but it would vastly change the
ecosystem if not destroy all life on
planet with a character like graviton
who is able to manipulate the
gravitational pull of the planet Earth
which kind of originates due to the
density of the core of the planet it's
not entirely impossible for him to keep
you know stop the planet from spinning
it's possible for him to simply move
entire land masses you know to simply
relocate the entire North American
continent somewhere else to relocate
Australia or Africa these are powers
that are entirely within or these are
abilities that are entirely within his
power range now the spite that we have
the fact we have not seen him do that
doesn't mean that he's not capable with
a character like Iceman for example we
didn't know that he was an omega-level
character until Emma Frost took over his
body and pushed his powers to their
extreme limits in which case when she
was done she backed out of his mind and
said this guy is incredibly powerful he
just doesn't know how powerful he is yet
and in fact there was a point I think
when Iceman asked her asked him a frost
to teaching him how to achieve that
level of power and she said something
long lines that you'll learn on your own
in which case he went to storm and a
storm to teach him you know how to
control his abilities more so than
Xavier had some who because their
abilities are very very similar so the
one thing to bear in mind here is that
when it comes to a person or a mutant
who or even just a an experiment gone
wrong like Franklin Hall when it comes
to someone who's able to manipulate
fundamental forces of the earth it puts
them on an extremely powerful scale and
just because of the fact that they have
the ability to theoretically eliminate
all life on the planet at any one
particular point in time so with that
being said I'm gonna go ahead and ring
this video to an end let me know what
you guys think and I will catch you guys
later peace